a self-described wonderful vegan
landlord and that's a quote in New York
City is getting roasted after Banning
prospective tenants from cooking meat or
fish in their apartment she says she
doesn't want the smell drifting upstairs
into her own home some experts say the
practice is not illegal and is similar
to Banning smokers and that's not all
the vegan induced craziness Peta is
getting mocked after tweeting this
quote Supremacy is at the root of why
people think it's okay to eat other
animals
all right
um
Greg yes who wants a landlord who
monitors their lifestyle in in addition
to everything else what they eat when
you pay six thousand dollars a month to
live in an apartment I don't think
people are paying six thousand dollars a
month right I think when they're talking
about landlords they're talking about
like Apartments where people are PA you
know like you know I had a landlord in
Allentown I think that's what they're
talking about and this woman lives
upstairs yeah yeah yeah I think this
isn't like talking about a two a two
yeah so I'm always Pro landlord on that
I don't like smelly things I had great
landlords in Allentown Bob Smith he was
great let me park my car in the driveway
so I always side with them because
they're renting from people like me all
right so I'm bro you know I'm a young
guy I'm broke I'm a mess I don't clean
my clothes my sheets and smell I leave
things everywhere the worst smell or is
cat food smell so I think that if I were
a landlord I would ban cat food smell so
you have no problem with that yeah and
by the way it is supremacy I mean of
course it's Supremacy if you're eating
something you believe you're better than
them yeah if you have dominion over them
yes yeah all right well don't say that
Jessica this seems like an episode
straight out of the sign out of Curb
Your Enthusiasm the scary part is it's
real life
it's weird I was trying to figure out
like if this was really discrimination
or you could just have a preference for
for this and obviously the fact that it
came down so quickly means that someone
with the legalese information about this
did say that it could be discrimination
um it struck me as something that I knew
we would do as a topic but didn't really
bother me and
um yeah the Peta statement is completely
right like this makes us sound not fun
but Brian and I were talking about like
what's a thing that in a hundred years
people are going to look back and say
was so wrong about society and he's like
100 it's eating animals yep I agree and
liberalism
we did not say that actually in fact we
said quite the opposite okay Jesse New
York City human rights law has 14
characteristics that landlords are not
allowed to consider in deciding whether
to rent an apartment and they're the
classic protections raid age race family
status job source of income sexual
orientation it appears that they can
deny this
the word discrimination gets a bad rap
obviously racial discrimination is not
good being discriminating but you want
to have discriminating taste that just
means you're able to discriminate
so whether something is better or worse
than something else for instance If I'm
renting to somebody and they are in the
Philharmonic I don't want to have
someone playing the oboe all hours of
the night or an opera singer or what
about a newlywed couple that's going to
be banging on the headboards constantly
there are certain things as a landlord
where you live above someone else you
just don't want wafting like I would
never rip a Greg or anybody like if Dana
cooked I would not allow Dana to cook
but beef queso right I mean and that's
probably within the bounds of legal
parameters
how frequently they're going to have sex
well at least in New York you could
order seamless and that means you're not
cooking and then you throw it away you
can eat the meat in there um I guess
this is a very common practice like in
India and maybe it works there but it's
not going to work here at least for a
while and also just find your renters By
Word of Mouth like in the vegan
Community I'm sure there's a vegan like
Reddit surf in the boards chat yeah
but in the vegan Community they have
stuff like sauerkraut and kimchi and
Jack kimchi smells stinks horrible very
good for you yeah but it's super food
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else